[Music]
dining facilities actually history can
already a notice that sometime in the
Meiji era that the there has been the
trend or tendency that too many people I
mean in Japanese not necessarily
familiar with the Japanese tradition why
Japanese the piece of knowledge so if I
try to speak to the university student
and Aikido Haram at the university the
soil it I'm going to talk over the next
in a couple of hours
unfortunately or I regret to say that
majority of these are students cannot
necessarily understand what I'm talking
about
[Music]
too many students don't know about name
of very famous in Japanese history
[Music]
mother I try to make this somewhat
different from what I have done in the
past storage one man first let me talk
about Marie here Michigan since a young
man which my odious Insano Aikido
because I take so the second part of my
lecture is to better understand what is
Aikido Marie hey mr. sensei
you need to understand you need to carry
on just a minimum of knowledge so that's
what I see if I try to cover up is a
second important part as much as I want
it would be to take years
[Music]
chiana's even though hamas miksa because
what I'm trying to cover up is across
over 3,000 years including storied in
Japan the stories in China and story
stories I mean India but they all move
anything like it
so in the history the feature is why do
many different in our old ideologies are
imported from China from India however
Japan tradition is not completely
eliminated something exists before that
so always try to stand together
Tendai department so that tradition is
kept in Omaha these days as well so over
history let me repeat the Japanese
feature with the Japanese car
[Music]
however I didn't know about taneous
people so that means when I say those
days of wedding I was he was this shoot
20 years since all my judo offender was
computed second so the cake was younger
no comment
I was born in 1929 or the most over my
education school I mean was before the
last World War two when the learning of
judo kendo are the schools are former
eClinical so that means a comparison
unless we took judo kendo No
[Music]
when I become aware of whispers and say
I was a primary school people but once I
started I did feel many many things
Akita Komachi so original actually I was
indeed able to feel at what or what the
dojos practice reminded me the older
sodium I understood my father when I was
a boy but does you know what does your
sushi mundane thoughts cute - Santa -
mama
actually I hide myself there's no
sentiment I myself was born in Tokyo
however my house just us
[Music]
so this is coming
my ancestors hominid house had a bow and
arrow a practice field and also I'm
talking about my that's not what a
student for just for family members to
keep that tradition for vomiting
sightings not the one of the Muslim the
most important point of the bow and
arrows the practice needs no one
d keysto and never criticize others
practice but that style are not
necessarily widened in common for rather
the small island there are 20 different
aboard 20 different board are all the
schools in this morning decide you know
college they say Cosmo still young you
name actually like hunters who just
chasing up or with animals and games
that will be the way that they're using
bone marrow was not that was not the
same as a samurai the poor they deny
stealing you mangy paws on that cat a
mom who's young can make a question
since the
same since you know the fire was
important at telling us my love in Japan
adapt very quickly depression we the
other traditional war a battle field ops
the confidence that somewhere I still
practice very very hard on the same car
useless a constant immunity again some
Liana knock upon didn't psychotic man
actually a blackberry the all these
a-hunting persons as I mentioned earlier
the way they use there's no preparation
because they must be very quick
otherwise raccoon dogs and foxes all
running away
[Music]
the school so the when I started like
underneath the census story reminded me
what my father told me when I
and I am yes
[Music]
the former class are sick salty start a
6:30 in the morning and evening
[Music]
the after I joined with Shiva dojo one
of my my senior person he introduced to
training associations and he asked me if
I knew temple in the communal sense a
former name is Estelle was a senior to
the wishlist and say by six or seven the
when he was young when Japan and Russia
over 19,000 for to 1905 he was member of
Kazakhstan through the mud winter during
that he so many times he was he he stood
almost at the edge of death and he was
captured by Kazakh soldiers and they're
almost people and then his recurring
NATO then she she she was tonight since
they are so vulnerable it is believed
that you know
dr. una sensei is always prepared to
choose to die for his country so the one
year after the war finished the story
unfortunately you are very aggressive
ammonia and the life is the negative of
three months at the best so but he said
that you always probably told everybody
that I never had no concern about to die
so you should be okay you're fine but
then he just to money
she also denied so John Hancock but the
clarity she given us
second opinion however the people feel
about this case is about the death is
largely influenced depending upon the
been surrounding situation or
circumstances when he was in war he any
single even piece of concern about death
however the war finished he was then he
so he was
[Music]
someday they would
so what a good thing Korea but implement
actually because he's a very heavy he
was not entitled to have the passport
from the Japanese government so soon
he's a possible Network
he just attract you yet he just got the
passport thanks to help very famous
person in China and then he first went
to the United States and the mintus with
Martin and he's a very famous possible
to encourage how the young people to be
expected life then he measure measure
lean medical science then he went to he
he he
[Music]
so actually this is one grants a courier
toward the common sense a that year a
big hole in your chest and then if you
want to be just for me then instant
instantaneous here say yes even before
he became aware therefore is not
gentleman and then he spent three years
and Kereopa and the country Ginga and
the Himalaya Mountains and he's a
disease was not necessarily covered
however stopped but everything and then
when he was thirty years old the Chinese
Revolution happened and then back to
Japan he became a head once there he
became a head of a bank a banking
corporation in Japan but ideas after
that he just throw everything away from
business world and then he has started
his new solo
this is the huge department jr. - Fausta
quasi emotional
[Music]
not multi-core bringing yarmulke
so everybody here the godom people just
come that each panelist in Japan to
study something for example Aikido like
you know is virtually part of Japanese
culture and Japanese culture was a 1000
years was created and then in the world
3 the elements which did the green large
in fact in the process of Japanese
Japanese history and Japanese culture
involved one is assurance second one is
Confucius way and third one is the
Buddhism and surah the process of Japan
importantly Buddhism from India it's not
necessarily religions but more sort of
Indian philosophy how to manage and
control her mind for example it's been
mentioned earlier Karma Raja yoga this
was imported to Japan and then this was
then say integrated into a consolidated
mix of together the water
I may say with Japanese the traditional
journeys of the Confucius way then that
was origin have contributed to form the
Japanese culture you're familiar with
now and I must then identify to the very
important monks in the history who
brought the tremendous impact and in
that process along is a qu Chi he's a
given name after he passed away he his
even the Kobo Daishi was given that
Devendra and he was a tremendous
contributor to inform the Japanese a
culture he was a monk in Heian era in
Japan and he was deeply studied in the
mountain the police and mantra yoga and
then back to Japan and and then spread
over what he learned and the other
person other monkey's us are called the
sideshow he opened the temple after he
came back to Japan
near-total and he was also given the
name by Emperor as a danger of dashi so
these two form the basis to create
Japanese culture you're familiar with
now the ammonia Richman sensei up to
when he became sati various water he was
all mostly a student over police and
then he started and then in my summary
Japanese culture was formed with two
local staff the journalism and the
confusion and mixed with Indian
old-fashioned yoga at that time and then
also our Taoism and from China so but as
a result who essentially the way of
thinking how to come to a body and mind
is very similar
[Music]
there are many people who actually miss
elohim he was blown nearby here the COS
company was a former name of aguma
prefecture he was born in the coast the
currently it is called as a gamma
prefecture and he used to be an old
okusama group but after the war he lost
his master and then he quitted samurai
samurai way he educated over the rest of
his life
he's sold school and everybody please be
file to the paper you are keeping and
then ask me
so it would be uncertain item one which
one
[Music]
so now I just start talking about Aikido
wish before your senses like I mean but
just as which I believe very important
for you to learn how the Japanese
history and Japan's culture be informed
that we contributed a tremendous impact
which person said prohibited for his
life means token Douglas do I do
please refer to page one top section
title nine shadow means to meet you are
startled no me digas totally nothing
this doe amici are formed by three
pathway integrated together tsunami
she's got no michi Palma home wouldn't
swallow gee Dino sky Tecna being given
one is Sheena to the mind study this
this is the prevailing social ethics
ethics for the politician afflicted by
her name's amber occupy onion sushiro my
quotient panel summarized by Gerardo
Parra dr. cheeto
in a total commitment so I think he find
the general you know context they feed
in fact she knew the for the supply the
group Sheena who means the confidence
way
Confucius you know thoroughly and but in
Japan that was has been over the years
mixed with you know Chinese and there
isn't
so students named Tala compassion is not
visible same mortgage how much is like
emotional say no which is an additional
tobu god on a whole thing stable
she actually whilst we correctly called
a Bushido as a one degree however the
Bushido is not the same not exactly the
same depending upon the year Bushido at
the initial period Kamakura here foreign
to Shido in Karachi England war period
who are the Takanawa after our these the
Shogun government and the assistance of
sense of time so the personality
differently at different to cheer him on
home he too many new enemies
for example how to directly to the role
in Kamakura the Muromachi or Japanese
island in the war period a song right
they didn't mind to work for the
different different different poses
so unless his ability his preparation
was properly devoted he didn't want to
change the boss however once the Shogun
governance system was settled in Okinawa
second - ah WA then reality means
working only for one
so they sumo
Bushido Bakugan don't worry not to me
samurai haunted iron on - Angelina so no
samurai teaching opposite text on my car
saheiji no penny obtain some well social
Bushido Oh God
may I show show another to the sunlight
period rusted about the same 700 years
old to the end Okinawa here samurai
abiding service very hearty are the
wicked
samurai are video samurai culture is no
longer effective so they decided to
change it but that was still continued
in a different means royal to Agra and
then royal to your own country so it is
under study for Momiji
- so many titles Quran cannot skycutter
not Jesus namida
say in Portuguese so she she - no
comment Sagarika so the second one you
can find the ship on which simple amici
is the methodology to Train how to
manage and how to use your mind how to
concentrate and that this is a part of
the science
Colonel Mitchell startling
auto-corrected
stotra - gracias for Rasta food
[Music]
so this way you know the woman thank you
that I'm not reading books on art about
the Japanese culture the feature it is
basically formed by the very developed
by Kobo Daishi
and also now also as part of Confucius
so no educator mr. Khan is totally not
pointing them on Miche total say dr. Q
equals a constant
yes lady Salman is not Obama so machine
for Miss adopted in Christ a young woman
so the this moment in Japan current
Japan I mean is 99
people if you are they are given the
world over me chief though they 99% of
the people understand tend to understand
that is why we say Gosa but they can't
okay no tena ninguna Conti sorry
Neotech did I totally current taking up
school are you - good
200 Jews
[Music]
they actually went ass online video if
there's a format you have finished this
was developed as a part of the school
education system and then Kendall was
also integrated into the school
education system these school system
with the tremendous emphasis on
scientific way to develop however very
regrettably that lost very spiritual
important part of oriental philosophy
part has been diluted and also the one
thing that brought the tremendous impact
is an image a year there is a group
strongly driven by a schism to get me to
a bashar and all the these that the
police of the temple and the policeman
statues so they move everything related
to the police they did this driven by
assurance
[Music]
Oh
so the the one problem on once on there
everything was the old commercial ours
was developed then as a part of a
student equation system program that the
problem is if everything is official too
much to the systematic way the people
just will start pursuing easy way to
learn an easy way to develop and then so
that change almost completely historic
all about the relative way to join the
martial arts for example the instructors
are teachers just let's chill until we
do the free and then bring a fun joy
enjoyment smiles all these things and
then that is easier that will be
understood by the majority of the
student so to the contrary to the
traditional way the Shambhala is not one
enough lifetime commitment and with the
tremendous emphasis on the basics and
others over the lifetime here forward
but this was hugely the time and effort
required so very hard for everybody to
for so in short the the when the summer
idea was finished and everything becomes
so easy
and there are instantaneous and the
concerts so that kill this is a very
important part of a traditional
methodology to train an Amazon martial
arts in this remove and crush everything
related to the Buddhism there was a some
sort of background of Japan in that
period over a token or video in Japan
the many years and applied across
national policy and then when Japan open
it country some the Japanese leaders a
day I believe the majority major
European country or alighted States of
America there a symbolic spiritual
backbone is a Christensen so okay these
guys are stood back bone is a Christians
must bow Japan that should be shining so
then I see all items right to the boot
remove anything else and but in the RT
if we have a chance to look at the
sample Japanese martial arts years such
as helmet on board question government
over the Japanese a summer and so you
can find some parts
somewhere inside is you can find mantra
yoga so this yoga distance is still a
very important part of the Japanese with
culture and let's not be totally booth
and the family the Japanese haunting a
fast pass well this one no no no second
and they however surprisingly the
traditional in Japan now you can find in
more and Western countries you are
nobody
introduced mental management moment are
trained that was exactly
[Music]
Cheeta
so what you try to what interest me I
think actually that time no good hi hi
cake recording system available that
time
so all these reporters who pick up words
or comments or messages for movers
person asylum that then summarize report
and one one thing is as you can see this
is so smooth means
creation 1990 this is a soul of the
challenge of the language this this
character if we refer to the language
dictionary the boo is normally
translated into English as of martial
arts however this does not necessarily
the martial arts so this is a challenge
of the language Bluto a woman named Miss
Melanie context this same Chinese
character represent occasionally not
essentially actually there was a summer
report which was in February 1945 so
that means even still Japan is and
therefore teased about the receiver
sensei's discussion with mr. Xie Toshi
Takahashi young knight but you know that
time
[Music]
so actually after this discussion this -
security let me just introduce what he
what
that is the every every single single
stuff not on the human being everything
including the flowers and animals
whatever available in the universe so
every single stuff in the universe is
parties at us now by the universe and
since day one
like forever after the blossom spilled
over the seas and the generate the next
generation with flowers on us to me even
the single glasses I try to grow up
these are the tasks original task when
they started after life is stuff and
given by the universe so what does who
means the process
well Airport are to perform the task
they given by each line however that is
not you can see in the language
dictionary language station is not
introduced this as what does this is a
Aikido magazine temperature response of
my past would entertain secretly dinner
it's mine
[Music]
so that was actually because you start
to include the music
I
[Music]
I actually Japan the soul of a
traditional style of solar plane only by
either haiku means they're only 17
characters and the waka is on this
healthy one our characters to summarize
and also said that the very well and the
terrain when we are talking particularly
Aikido it is very important to how make
yourself the sensitivity' how do you
feel not how logically think about so it
is very important to cultivate and
empower your the power over the feeling
and whilst I I should say you should not
think about anything but when you need
to think something but now you need to
think about something however for like
you know that particularly the instances
we could radically of emphasis on and
the power of the field then the just
left me a little supplement about
Japanese a Shinto shrine the I penis
wine was actually built by Sansa and all
since I caught occasionally introduced
Aikido as meditation Misaki Zoe III
transfers me so he as a meditation but
this is my sake is a very much
tango G and Sherman which party shows si
when he had a discussion with dices -
Suzuki the famous Buddhist monk he
explained about the the shamisen is a
very unique and extremely the Japanese
are very much Japanese and Chinese it's
a measure difference between tsunamis
around any other major religions are
surrealism has no Honda video was just
in the Profi in history and created very
naturally and because it was so
[Music]
is she talking about
he actually let me just meet her at my
worst
it also speculation we introduced Aikido
sov sov the simple transpiration is a
meditation and the aikido was like to
use years ago in European countries as
active meditation active and in 1964
when Japan hosted the first Olympic
Games in Tokyo the year I met Italian
professor peter Patton and he is a
person we were transferred to one shot
to Italian language and he clearly he
understood that Aikido or Japanese Budo
be so different from sport and then
suddenly that if we say I do is active
sin or if we say Aikido is active or
bovine meditation then we have the
question of what is sin what is
meditation then I I just a tort Aikido
over the last 50 years in many European
countries and I found that what European
style meditation what Japanese which
segmentation not exactly the same but it
is very difficult to explain of what our
differences and also the meditation able
the meaning or the presence of a
meditation is different from time to
time somebody may ask me why you are
spending so much time the lifetime
effort for the Aikido exercise or
practice was study ideal if you spend
the same time and same effort to develop
a new medicine that could potentially
save hundreds millions of people's life
so what is more important stop wasting
your time too
like no too much so then
but if opportunity the meaningless then
I get all whiny so the traditional
martial arts who knew happy completely
eliminated years ago but when samurai PU
as we mentioned Arya samurai even after
the unified firearms was introduced for
still has not stopped practicing
Bordeaux every single day continuously
kept a port for what
so actually barrel I'm talking about the
monster book for succession from a
teacher to the student to keep the
particular master school and normally
these group have two parts alone is
largest a description about that
particular schools the webinar is the
most general knowledge
[Music]
when actually I explained this the
substitution we introduced which covered
a community and also included musashi
miyamoto hi guya seconds books and
particularly measure the
I know
[Music]
making changes to one cute
these these are based upon the Confucius
Verity and kind of introduce the way of
thinking when we when we practicing
Aikido we have to identify two
nature of different conditions one is
the global conditions the other one
universal conditions for example the
first one the always mentioned to me
that probably I believe are I am
convinced that our life is just as long
as a life of the universe when I first
given when the universe was started our
universe was formed this is a very much
oriental philosophical a way of thinking
and so what does it mean it means unless
some sort something is recognized by the
universe that something can never ever
ecosystem so that means exists the
presence means that was a sign of
recognition by the universe and that's
all the the how we can identify a
universal conditions or regulations or
rules whatever I may say it is important
for us to actually perform and there the
degradation on identify the what is our
soul changes soul is the skill set how
to win the battle however if we are
contemplating a skill or what so many
calls on techniques too much then that
we would tend to forget about something
more important sees it as something
important thing is how to use and trying
mind and body and so I should not jump
up and down too much about the skill set
so in summary the global condition is
more like a system the the universal
condition is how to empower you our life
energy and how to make sure the
longevity of their life and how to make
sure you you should never catch a
disease so last term's of us if you
catch a disease and how to fix it how to
recover from disease as quick as
possible
pathology oh ah oh ah who are the way to
issue an illusion between the Hennessy
life or quarterback the soul IQ are the
same same main objective learning a soul
Aikido is to run the the power of the
life the power of our affinity and
identify that's why you should not go
into karate so what I just like I met is
a summary on the white bodies this is
sort of a key message even tonight and
this is a two different way to develop
and vast majority particularly Hospital
frita 24 fall into this pathway so mind
then is attached to the object
Oh today I show me their object c'mon
over by me hi Shirley
Toto Buddha mention 416 before the mind
is are taxed addicted obviously much
this this is a vacancy in the pension
so when the money's attached to here too
much 30 the object the this a succession
you know martial arts booklet as I this
is kg kg meter in crying to detachment
or he crying to have years
tomorrow
nothing the very famous moon contractor
on leave not introduce your didi it is
minded that attach other hear something
it's a mind always moving around
devastated whatever I did okay okay so
for example even Aikido somebody strikes
me if my mind attached too much fun here
too much an object then my response is
how to escape how to step aside so
because of this all comes from
and other young my mind they stick to
the ocean too much arjan yah - Surya
my own castle so stay cool go go -
exactly
and then if we can't catch disease then
then so there are you
[Music]
thank you and when they was promised and
he said that similar very famous yoga
people to the Moscow and their
aberrantly and at that time was actually
Indian ambassador and explained you know
currently about the second of hi
colossal yoga people in violet and Oscar
and then sue yoga's metrology then how
to empower and the develop the best way
of training that you sports or
particularly Oscar most recently so this
is a negative development this is
nothing to do with a philosophy this is
[Music]
choo-choo-choo-choo concentration Falls
yawning semaj Obama there are not so
many
so this second the yogurt Anjani
explained that you know the people are
strongly recommended to do it only
adducing don't kill somebody don't don't
make a lie and the focus on not doing
only a good thing and the good thing or
in other words means a positive thing
don't know- say so and then you are fast
and yourself on the starting point to
start creating the body art which is
benefit also for your life and the your
body must be a flexible enough and
natural not Tobuscus and then the the
yoga asana says the mythology to make
proper zazen then the how to intake
energy this system and ferocity
introduced as a pranayama in Japanese as
you do the breathing methodology and
this is a way to how effectively and
efficiently an intake key energy from
the universe then first of all that was
internal and external condition are set
to lady and we can better control
ourselves then everything moved to a
positive way from concentration to
unification than summation usually this
name you know what they do it
not the boss enemies I got men stationed
to be fertile at about 8:30 to 10:00 -
come by France upon your servant
supuesto
[Music]
so y % introduce meditation in the
dynamic neural rotation UK tradition
back at the preparation time interaction
is important and repair company name is
Antonio
[Music]
22:22 host of
so
technical so when I
[Music]
so the let patients that summarize again
some single people I already covered but
they've others so important thing is you
must be a full attention to the everyday
life
don't just Medusa nation doing all the
positive things don't do any bad things
or negative things and then in short and
create the your body which is always
really food from the selection by a bite
and there is no society always represent
that we train body as if it were the
phosphorus a musical instruments so if a
body is a first-class instrument your
mind to be the first class musician or
artist and the purpose of war that
condition allow you to maximize optimize
that in take capacity of key energy and
then the energy it is normally the
present to present as a form of weight
so it is very important for you to sue
the vibration and continuously vibrate
and then then the key is vibrated by a
breathing exercise and the vibration is
a process to empower the idioma then you
can control you are feeling the power of
healing then your mind is working like a
mirror instead of mind is attaching who
auto here
stick to some too much mind
reflect the object as very clearly like
a mirror then the disorder in Chinese of
yoga in his booklet introduced after day
the objective is to train and use your
mind as if it were a Bella and then this
situation we call angel the what angel
means you can see in the middle part of
the page one of this paper and then once
we then come to that stage then we are
in the position to use our mind as
integration or consolidation another
confrontation or TransAm and we call
young confrontation and then that
situation is called as Deanna and then
translated into said so this situation
and the enemy does not exist
none of the enemy in front of you or in
front of us then our mind is completely
free and freedom is guaranteed then as a
comment the Aikido is a metal Rotozip a
process to take everybody to the idea
and we every single one of us as a first
class artist to whom we utilize time
given rest by demons
so in this racket of magazine says
Aikido is art of creation
[Music]
I doesn't have a confession because the
objective is not to create anything not
to create the mind of confrontation or
we should go beyond confrontation so the
the composition or compact and about is
like very much animal like training
methodology which does not fit if our
objective is to be a human being not in
a global condition but in the universal
conditions so once we appreciate for
ourselves including ourselves a
universal condition no point for us to
just you know stepping down to the
departed Agnes Karina yeah my oh my oh
my god
so the how you did with the disease the
same thing if you catch a disease or you
are getting older and using a healthier
body conditions then my question is are
you than fighting against these disease
it is tough and very difficult so the
important thing is you can some feel yes
are you can do this you are a body
condition is not necessarily the best
however as this page one the medium part
the current undulation which is to
meditate you don't need the picture as a
landscape a when the mind is destroyed
the fire itself or wilfy are very cool
refreshing Li the cook so this is all
comes from your mindset so the the point
is we try to integrate the ourselves
into the vibration through the
population unfortunately diet time is
running out I try to continue the what I
wanted to say
tonight I try to cover the the part of
my tomorrows decision across but they
can sell because martial arts or
meditation has an orang asli pants leave
our entire history there are many many
many different methodologies so I decide
to teach us some of that for you the
most important theorem you are suggested
to another recommended to do everyday is
making the sound the result in our
physical sound vibration the vibrate
your nervous system and the try to
integrity of consulted yourself into the
vibration so that is very training
methodology for you to move yourself to
this side not decide your muscle but
something also which gives you good
morning so our bodies let me conclude my
lecture tonight and the next is I'll be
19 years old I'm not sure
[Applause]